I believe in free trade but I also
believe it's important because it's a
bull work to China
and I urge our British government and
any future British government that they
must never allow China to join the cptpp
what we need to find is ways of trading
in a deep way with our friends and
allies not with those who are seeking to
undermine us and seeking to undermine
freedom and democracy
now I hope that the US will reconsider
pulling out of the TPP
it was a U.S initiative in the first
place I believe it was a good idea and
if the U.S joins
first of all it will be of benefit to
U.S consumers
secondly it will help strengthen
indo-pacific security and finally now
that the UK is a member it will be a
fast track route to a UK US trade deal
what is not to like
and now more than ever I believe
our relationship our strength is needed
because we've got to ask ourselves after
the success of winning the Cold War why
is it that authoritarians are on the
March around the world and of course
is President Putin who's responsible for
the appalling actions in Ukraine
but we have to ask ourselves
what was it about
what we did
that we could have done differently
and I fear that we showed weakness
we didn't invest enough in our defense
we didn't make sure that we were
economically robust
and we made it easier
for Putin to act with impunity
and at the heart of that at the heart of
that is the fact there are economies
simply haven't been growing fast enough
we've seen low growth now
for several decades
and this is particularly cute acute in
the United Kingdom
real incomes haven't increased
significantly since the financial crisis
and the average GDP per capita in the UK
is now 30 less than it is in the United
States
that is not a good position for us to be
in it was much closer
two decades ago
the symptoms that we're seeing are low
growth
we're seeing
High Cost of Living
and we're seeing real wages
in having declining value
the disease
is ever larger government and we have to
ask ourselves
with our economies in the state they are
now
are we going to be match fit to take on
China in the decades ahead and are we
going to be able to make the case
that are a model
anglo-american capitalism is better
than Chinese State capitalism
the sad truth is what I think we've seen
over the past few years
is a new kind of economic model taking
hold in our countries one that's focused
on redistributionism
on stagnation
and on the imbuing of woke culture into
our businesses
I call these people the anti-growth
movement and they come in many shapes
and sizes
through the vested interest you don't
want Challenge and don't want
competition they've always been there
but they've been joined by socialists
and environmental clothing who in the
name of combating climate change insist
that we should simply stop virtually
every kind of economic activity
and then we have the ESG culture
perpetrated by many in big corporations
where the focus is on hitting our
diversity Target or putting a social
Target rather than actually generating
money
for employees and for the country
and of course this Model results in more
taxes it results in more subsidies and
it results in more regulation I think we
can see that with President Biden's
inflation reduction Act
is going to cost U.S taxpayers 400
billion dollars
is going to encourage U.S industry to
spend their time rent seeking and going
to the government for those subsidies
and it's also going to cut competitors
out of the market including companies in
the United Kingdom
another good example is the UK ban of
bracket
this is despite the fact that energy
costs in the UK are twice what they are
in the United States
and what we are now doing
is we are buying gas from America
fract gas
we are freezing it to minus 260 degrees
Fahrenheit
we're transporting it across the United
across the Atlantic Ocean and then we're
re-gasifying it in Britain now why on
Earth does that make economic or
environmental sense it simply doesn't
or what about our defense industries
that are struggling to get investment
because they're not themed socially
acceptable just as a time when we are
using more Weaponry to help support the
ukrainians
our defense Industries aren't able to
raise the funds they need in all cases
because of some of these ESG
requirements
across the board what we see is it's
getting harder and harder to get things
done and it's getting harder to get on
overall
the anglo-american model of capitalism
is being subverted and the Heritage
Foundation itself in its own index of
economic freedom has shown
that the U.S and the UK are falling down
the league table
and in fact the uh UK has now fallen
behind Germany in terms of our level of
economic freedom
I fear
that our countries are becoming social
democracies by the back door
and we've ended up in a culture where
too many people and too many businesses
expect a bailout
now one of the core beliefs of Margaret
Thatcher was the belief in personal
responsibility it was the idea that it's
down to you how you get on in life that
through your own ideas your own hard
work for your family you can make your
way in the world that was the core idea
but I think that nation has been eroded
and I think we can all understand why
back in the financial crisis many people
who made the wrong decisions in the
banks didn't feel the full
responsibility and accountability for
what they've done they were bailed out
and lots of people ask the question well
if we're going to bail out some of the
richest people in our society why
shouldn't I be entitled to some money
from the government and that's the
culture we've created so we've ended up
in a situation following the financial
crisis and following covid where there
was even more money given out and
supplied by the government and in the UK
that amounted to 400 billion pounds I
think in the US it was five trillion
dollars
We've Ended up in a situation
where people see the government as the
concierge
I've got a problem
I'll call the government
you know my business is failing
I'll get on the phone and sort it out my
investment isn't doing very well
it's the government's problem I can't
buy a house
I need to call the government
but I can tell you as somebody who's
worked in government for many years that
is not the answer and it's not
sustainable
I don't think people really understand
how big the government's actually got
if you listen to some of the left-wing
Media or the left-wing commentators you
would think we're living in some kind of
Ayn Rand skeletal state thank you
it's not true
at the turn of the millennium
the state was spending 29 and 36 percent
of national income
in the United States and the United
Kingdom
today those figures are 35 in the U.S
and 47 in the UK
that is virtually half of every pound in
Britain is now being spent by the state
it all makes makes the eras of Bill
Clinton and Tony Blair look like some
kind of libertarian Paradise
and I really worry that if we don't
change course now
those figures are going to get even
worse
because all of this state spending just
creates more demand
more demand for subsidies more demand
for higher taxes more demand for
regulation it becomes a vicious circle
and everybody who's affected the
entrepreneurs the businesses the
landlords
they look to the government rather than
looking to what they could do to get on
and this has been aided and abetted by
the central banks
with artificially low interest rates
pumping more money in and keeping that
whole system going
now the reason I'm in politics and the
reason I remain in politics
is I don't believe
that's what ordinary voters want I don't
believe that this is the society
that people in Main Street in the US or
the High Street in the UK actually want
to see
I believe that people want to have
control of their own lives develop their
own Futures have their own businesses I
don't believe they want to be dependent
on government handouts
people aspire to a higher standard of
living they want their children to have
a better life than they had and that is
what we have to deliver but it's
becoming harder and harder to deliver in
this low growth world that we're now
living in
now when I was in number 10 Downing
Street
I tried to change this
I think if you are
somebody who's not worked in government
you perhaps don't understand quite how
hard it can be to get things done
and to make that change
Boris Johnson said it was like one of
those nightmares where you simply can't
move your feet
Tony Blair talked about the scars upon
his back and I'd spent many years in
government I knew it would be difficult
but I still didn't understand
quite how hard
in my 10 years as a minister I've seen
all kinds of producer interests
whether it was the legal establishment
the education establishment the
environmental establishment the
agricultural establishment
all of these groups often don't want to
see the status quo changed
there are people who
work in businesses that invoice the
government and they're doing quite fine
thank you very much
there are executive agencies who like
having power without having
responsibility
and there are also the people who live
in the Beltway
or they live in London they live within
the M25
and they've been enjoying quite a nice
life
they've been enjoying high asset prices
cheap goods from around the world
cheap labor
and they're comfortably off they don't
want to see the status quo changed
all of those people are part of the
resistance to the change we need to see
and as prime minister
I simply underestimated the scale and
depth of this resistance
and the scale and depth to which it
reached into the media and into the
broader establishment
my plans for tax cuts and supply side
reform were about making Britain more
competitive they were about making us a
more successful country where we were
less reliant on government and I told
you we were up to 47 percent
those plans were backed by conservative
members across the country
but we Face coordinated resistance and
we didn't just face coordinated
resistance from inside the conservative
party
or even inside the British corporate
establishment
we faced it from the IMF
and even from President Biden
so my warning
to you here today
is this not enough just to have the
right ideas
it's not enough even
to have broad support for those ideas
we need to be able to take on those who
resist change and who don't want change
and we need to be able to ensure that
we're winning the argument enough to be
able to do that and we need to start
preparing now
because we're now facing a wider problem
which is one of the reasons that I've
come here today to
Washington and come to the Heritage
Foundation
the national stagnation problem that
I've been talking about in both the US
and the UK
is now becoming an international problem
because not content with high taxes in
their own countries
we see governments seeking to agree high
taxes around the Free World
I'm talking about the oecd minimum tax
agreement which will stop countries
lowering things like corporation tax and
becoming more competitive
in my view is nothing short of a global
cartel of complacency
because what will be the effect of these
high taxes
well it will mean lower growth it will
mean higher spending
and it will mean ultimately that we are
less competitive against our adversaries
around the world and less economically
strong
and what we're seeing is those on the
left of politics working together to put
policies in place across the Free World
that essentially tie the hands of
governments and prevent them taking the
actions to making their economies more
free
and their economies more successful and
I believe in the way that those people
are working together we who believe in
low taxes who believe in free enterprise
need to work together to combat
those challenges
so how do we do this because it's a
massive task and frankly things have
been moving in the wrong direction for
some time
well first of all we need to start
at the core problem which is the
challenge to our
core anglo-american values
we've allowed our opponents to fill the
airwaves
we've allowed them to crowd our campuses
and we've allowed them to use our
institutions to undermine our values
we share a great heritage of Freedom
between our two countries
the U.S Constitution Magna Carta there
are many founding documents
that I could mention
but that freedom is being undermined
and of course we need to be
self-critical
we we should subject ourselves to
self-examination We Believe in a free
press
but what I think it's come to is
self-flagellation
self-flagellation of the values that
made our countries great in the first
place
identity politics which is basically the
idea that what group you're in
is more important than the person you
are
critical race Theory
which says it's more important how you
appear on the surface
than what your talents and attributes
are
or
the whole debate
about what is a woman
that completely subverts basic
principles of Science and biology
these are all
core
beliefs that we have seen being
undermined and I'm afraid there hasn't
been sufficient fight back now
before I was prime ministerized minister
for women inequalities and one of the
things I did is I stopped gender self ID
in Britain without a medical certificate
but that is what had been happening in
Britain
but what we don't see is we don't see
enough people prepared to take the
Orthodoxy on
and I find it ironic
that there's so much criticism within
our own societies and yet so many people
also trying to migrate to our countries
I know that the United States has
problems that the Mexican border we have
problems in the English Channel with
small boats
and we're in a situation where people in
our own societies appear to be
questioning the very value
of what we are whilst others are
desperate to get into the country and
it's an extraordinary contradiction
so what can we do about all this
because this isn't just a problem about
our own Societies or our own countries
this is a problem for the future of the
world that we need to deal with
we need to be as organized and we need
to be as Fearless as our opponents
and first of all we need to be proud of
our core values and we need to tell the
story of Freedom again
we need to make sure
that people understand the benefits of
living in a free Society they need to
understand what individual liberty means
we need to challenge those who seek to
cancel people and we need to be brave in
speaking out and we need to challenge
those who subvert the law of biology and
there's only one thing we can do which
is speak out every time this happens we
need to be intolerant of intolerance
and we need to tell the truth about what
happened during the Cold War I find it
incredible that the younger generation
now
seem more favorably inclined towards
communism and socialism
we need to tell the story
of the crimes that took place in the
USSR the types of society
that existed then and we need to tell
the truth about how Freedom delivered
and how it was achieved
the second thing we need to do is
recapture the language
the left of weaponized people's concerns
about the economy and environment using
terms like fuel poverty and the climate
emergency to justify policies which are
anti-grace and socialists
maybe we should talk about Rising taxes
as tax poverty and the fact that we have
the highest taxes for 70 years as a tax
emergency
and maybe rather than the cost of living
crisis what we've actually got is a cost
of government crisis
we need to reduce the size of government
and make our economies match fit
we live in a big government era and the
problem with that of course is a lot of
people with an interest in the
government remaining big
so we can't win the battle without
changing those incentives
we should follow the example of U.S
states like Florida and Texas that are
changing things whether it's on
occupational licensing
tax cuts school choice these are the
types of policies we need to pursue and
we also need to look at countries like
Poland and the Czech Republic in Eastern
Europe
and their economic dynamism
fourthly Believers in Freedom need to
link up across the Atlantic and Beyond
we need a network of Liberty not a
cartel of complacency
we need a UK U.S trade deal not a UK U.S
tax deal
and we need a race to the top we
shouldn't be putting regulations on each
other
I would love to see America ReDiscover
free trade and reject protectionism or
as President Reagan calls it
destructionism
that doesn't mean we should allow piracy
intellectual property theft or unfair
State subsidies I believe we should be
much tougher on trade with China
and acting with friends in the G7 we put
sanctions on Russia we can use trade
restrictions on China to force change
I want to see the UK adopt the
technology restrictions on China that
the U.S and Netherlands have as a
starting point
in conclusion
I presented quite a gloomy picture over
the past 30 minutes I can see the
audience agree of what's happening in
our countries and the threats we face
but I don't believe hope is lost I don't
believe this for a minute
because we've been here before
we know what it feels like I was born in
the 1970s which was a dark decade for
Britain a dark decade of industrial
crisis but what we saw
is we saw the birth of new ideas we saw
an intellectual Revival on the free
right and then we saw the election of a
conservative prime minister Mrs Thatcher
in 1979 who won hearts and minds and
changed our country and together with
President Reagan change the future of
the world
last Autumn I had a major setback
but I care too much to give up on this
agenda I think it's too important
and I know there are others who care to
I know there are people who care in the
UK I know there are people who care in
the U.S and Beyond
and over the coming months I'll be
setting out ideas about how we together
can take this battle forward we all need
to think about what we can do
we need to get real
about the threat from authoritarian
regimes and their unwitting allies
in the anti-growth movement in the West
we need to get organized about taking
these forces on
and we need to fight this battle of
ideas
once again
Mrs Thatcher would have expected nothing
less
thank you
[Applause]
prime minister thank you very much for a
tremendous speech for inspiring a speech
and
a robust thatcherite
address here in Washington DC at a
critically important time I think for
the for the future of the free of the
Free World
and we have uh time for a few a few
questions and uh I'm going to
um uh kick off
with um question on one of our favorite
topics here at Heritage Emmanuel macron
and the French
and uh
as you reference in your in your
excellent speech um
the French president was just in in
Beijing
and one might say
um cow Towing to the the Chinese
communist government
and his visit received a great deal of
condemnation
not only here in the United States but
also across much of much of Europe
and his uh his message about strategic
autonomy about standing apart from the
United States
and why in his view Europe should keep
out of the um the conflict over Taiwan
um he was practically repeating the the
talking points of of Beijing and so an
extraordinarily uh damaging visit in so
many respects
um could you uh elaborate more on your
views with regard to Emmanuel macron's
visit and its impact
uh and and what should be the the
response of the United Kingdom and the
West
so I remember growing up in the 1980s
and um
although I'm a conservative my parents
were quite left-wing and I remember this
sort of talk in left-wing circles at the
time was that
there wasn't really much difference
between the USSR and the USA they were
both sort of superpowers fighting it out
and there was a sort of moral
equivalence uh between the two of them
and that's what it that's what this
feels like it feels like the idea of
moral equivalence and it simply isn't
true China is a totalitarian regime run
by somebody who's explicit aim is to
impose
their way of thinking on the world and
to undermine freedom and democracy which
is what they've already done in Hong
Kong and are now seeking to do in Taiwan
now I'm not saying everything
America has done
in the history is perfect no country's
perfect but this is a free democracy
this is a free democracy that shares our
values France is also a democracy that
is much much much more important and
that what was good about the uh response
to the Warren ball perpetrated by Putin
is the G7 worked together and I still
believe it is vital that Europe and the
United States and the United Kingdom all
work to get work together to Candle
authoritarianism but
the idea that we can treat China as just
another
Global player is is wrong it is a
totalitarian regime and we need to adapt
our policies accordingly and we need to
be much more skeptical about what is
said uh by China and what their promises
are and we need to make sure that we are
working together as an alliance so I
don't agree at all with the visit by
Ursula vanderline and macron I think it
was a mistake I think it showed a divide
in the west which doesn't exist and I
also believe that we should be much much
tougher on supporting Taiwan at this
juncture
thank you um for those excellent remarks
and uh with regard to uh macron's talk
of European strategical autonomy
and his support for the idea of somewhat
some might call call it a delusional
call for a European Union Army
uh do you see this as a as a threat to
the future of the NATO alliance uh this
this idea of having sort of competing
European Union Military uh capability
and do you think that you know macron's
vision for for the future of Europe is
uh is is fundamentally unhelpful for the
transatic lives
so I I don't agree with the idea of a
European Army I believe that NATO is a
very successful Alliance and the fact
that new countries are seeking to join
NATO all the time is a demonstration of
its success and I believe it would make
a huge difference if Ukraine joined NATO
and we should be fast tracking Ukrainian
membership of NATO I think we we have to
be real that if you look at the G7
economies overall is rough plus the EU
it's roughly 50 of world GDP that is a
powerful economic force that is capable
of forcing change
and we should be using that together but
if there's a division between the US and
the EU then that's simply uh
that that simply doesn't create in my
view enough pressure on Beijing to
change and what Beijing will be trying
to do is divide and Rule and we should
resist that at every every possible
opportunity and
you know what I was saying in my talk is
the issues we are facing are now
you know the invasion of Taiwan
could come sooner
than we expect
we're already seeing the conflict taking
place in Ukraine this is not some Far
Away Prospect where there is time to
reinvent
the various alliances we have this is a
immediate threat to freedom and
democracy and
NATO has proven itself to be successful
I would like to see more uh
more of a freedom-based military
Alliance in the Pacific I think would be
very helpful as well but
I can't see what value a European Army
would add to that at all yes absolutely
practically none at all this factor and
uh
um on the issue of Taiwan is standing up
to Chinese aggression
um what more should the the US and the
UK and the West be doing right now
well I think the number one thing we
could do is more economic coordination
on China and show that we mean business
in terms of putting pressure on them uh
whether it's over what they've been
doing uh in xinjiang uh whether it's
the way they're trying to undermine our
Industries with State subsidies and
intellectual property theft I think we
should be putting much more economic
pressure on China I think ultimately
that is the best form of early defense
against an invasion showing we would be
serious
about decoupling if there was the
furthest threats to Taiwan
absolutely and only the subject of
U.S leadership this time
um you reference the issue of a global
cartel of complacency speech
and
uh and you were strongly critical of
course of uh the the big spending High
tax approach of these Biden presidency
and uh Joe Biden himself uh launched
what can only be described as an
extraordinary attack on
uh your government's tax policy when you
were a prime minister uh and uh this was
a highly controversial intervention by
U.S president
on a domestic British political issue
could you respond to to Biden's
intervention at that time
well the the
I mean I said in my speech that
this is this is in my view part of
International Group things that we're
seeing
and it was significant that the IMF
attacked the policy not on any issues of
financial stability but on the issues of
redistribution they thought the
redistribution was unfair that is not a
matter for the IMF it's not a matter for
the U.S president it's a matter for the
UK government how we best
how we best have tax rates that deliver
for everybody across our country and
this is what I worry about as well with
the oecd minimum tax proposals so these
these matters and we spend years in the
EU arguing about these things these
matters which should be a matter for
national government
are now becoming something that
other countries get involved in them I
think that is disastrous I think it's
anti-competitive and damaging
so I object to it on two levels one
level is we shouldn't be setting taxes
internationally
but the level two is I don't believe we
should have high taxes and I think in
too many countries we have
left-wing governments in power who want
high taxes and rather than justifying
those policies on their own terms they
want to stop anybody else undercutting
them and I think that is
that is a problem for the Free World and
it's a problem for Freedom overall
because it is not making our economies
any more successful and you know I
pointed out where we were in terms of
the size of the state you know the
Millennium the US was below 30 and we
were below 40 percent
that you're now at 36 we're not 47
you know the story is only going to end
One Way Nile
unless there is a change in U.S
government policy to be a
smaller government lower tax country
uh very very well said I'm sure ladies
actually would have partially agreed
with those sentiments and
um on the issue of
of brexit British sovereignty
self-determination
uh what more should the UK be doing
right now to take full advantage of
of its exit from the European Union is
enough being done also uh
would a labor government potentially
threaten the future
of brexit
well I think the audience might be
surprised to hear
that virtually all the EU laws that we
had when we were members of EU are still
on the statute books in Britain so I
think the first thing we need to do is
get those laws off the statute books and
start doing things differently because
that's what people expected when they
voted for brexit and I liken it to a
situation of getting divorced but still
living in the same house as your
ex-husband it doesn't make any sense you
know we have to actually deliver what
people voted for and they voted for
things to be different in Britain and
you know I talked about the
the sort of anti-grath movement and the
the sort of Coalition of complacency but
there's there are a group of people who
don't want things to change because they
are relatively comfortable with the way
things are now and they want to have
they wouldn't say this explicitly but
they like the idea of her steady decline
you know we're already 30 lower in terms
of GDP per capita than the United States
which I think is pretty shocking and
what what what people don't want to do
is they don't want to rock the boat and
doing things significantly differently
from the EU rocks the boat and we do
need to do it we do need to follow
through because we need to make
ourselves more competitive and what that
is about for me
is ultimately the people I represent
you know in places like Norfolk
they need to have the opportunities they
need to have the freedom to make their
businesses more successful and you can't
do that if you've got such big
government if you've got such really all
the EU regulations still on the statute
but it just makes it too hard to get
things done
uh very well said there and it's
outrageous that we still have EU law
prevailing over
uh big big sections of of
the United Kingdom and
uh on the issue of uh Britain's borders
uh on both sides of Atlantic
uh illegal migration
huge problem
uh our Britain's borders
secure enough what more needs to be done
what should be done about the echr and
British membership of the European
conventions human rights
there were this is a very
a very very big issue in Britain and it
is getting worse every year and
it the first thing we need to do
is we need to make sure
that our legal system works properly
because at the moment we have a lot of
activists lawyers we have a legal system
that enables uh people to constantly
appeal these decisions so we've got a
lot of people stuck in a backlog I know
that the Home Secretary is doing a lot
to improve what's happening on the
border and also improving things like
where people actually stay when they're
in Britain because
currently a lot of people are staying in
hotel accommodation for months and
months and months and that is a huge
problem as well it's not an easy nut to
crack on your ECR HR Point uh my viewers
we do need to be prepared to either
leave or disregard the echr if it is a
problem but the first thing we need to
do is address the impact of the Human
Rights Act in Britain I think there's a
lot of legislation that when we came
into government in 2010 like the human
rights act like the equality act that we
should have changed straight away
because what I don't think we realized
enough is that legislation changed the
culture in Britain it changed the way
government departments worked it changed
the legal culture and that has
had a very sort of tranquilizing effect
on getting things done in Britain
including proper deportation of illegal
migrants
and we have time actually for just one
last question and uh this will be on the
uh
on the broader cultural Wars again
a huge issue UK and in the United States
uh and you have been uh very
prominent in fighting against the woke
left
and uh as prime minister you certainly
led the charge against wokism in in the
United Kingdom
um could you talk a bit about how
British conservatives are fighting back
against the uh the the woke left's
cultural agenda and are there any
lessons for for the United States to be
gained
so I think where we have
made changes so for example not having
gender self-identification uh the Prime
Minister Rishi Cena has been very strong
uh against attempts in Scotland uh to
impose that agenda in Scotland I think
that has been very important so
government ministers have been out there
making the case and I think that's
important I think the left have
succeeded where people are silent you
know they've managed to infiltrate huge
amounts of the public sector huge
amounts of Institutions a large sways of
the media and what they rely on is
people being too afraid to take them off
so my main message is that we've been
successful where we've been prepared to
take them all uh not successful enough
in my view over things like the culture
in the public sector we need to do more
on that and we need to change the way
that works but I think on specific
issues is by being prepared to take them
on and finding people who are brave
enough to speak out is uh the important
lesson I would take
excellent uh this one thank you very
much for a absolutely superb Margaret
Thatcher uh lecture today it has been a
tremendous uh discussion here at the
Heritage Foundation and thank you for
all fuel leadership standing up for
conservative principles uh standing up
for uh tax cuts for limited government
and for economic freedom and it's been a
tremendous pleasure to you to host you a
hero today at the Heritage Foundation
thank you very much thank you
something